[Music]
[Music]
what are the most powerful creatures and
monsters from dungeons and dragons there
are a lot of them in the game as well as
some included in that old movie and some
that will be shown in a new movie that
is going to be released soon so here is
a list of 7 of the most powerful evil
entities from that universe
so let's get to it
wait before we go into the video do
check out two of our new channels one it
is called mind cue space which is
concentrated on prehistoric creatures
and all that jazz
and the other one is nutbug this is a
new channel and really needs your
support it is concentrated on ai
robotics new technology cars gadgets and
all of that so jump to those channels
and subscribe and help us get to this
level
at number 7 we have baylor
a powerful battle lord from the demonic
forces of hell
baylor or baylors which were many were
imposing humanoid figures that stood
about 12 feet or 3.7 meters tall and
weighed 4 500 pounds or more than 2 tons
a powerful aura of darkness envelops
their grotesque forms as their deep red
skin are wrapped in glaring flames they
have a pair of bat like wings and can
fly at fast speeds even with their heavy
weight
they have a couple of horns on their
heads venomous fangs terrifying claws
and arm with lightning swords and
multi-flame whips
number six we have the elder brain a
mind flare is a powerful entity but what
about one that is evolved to its
ultimate stage in its life cycle
an elder brain
the other brain strong mind affecting
power stemmed from the brains of long
dead mind flayers making up its vicious
mass that is 3 meters or 10 feet wide
and has numerous long tentacles forming
the physical and spiritual center of a
mind flare community the elder brain
serves as a living library of the
community's history technology and
knowledge it could also cast spells as
an extremely powerful sorcerer making it
an opponent to be
feared number 5 the draco lich
ancient dragons or dragons
are powerful creatures and near
impossible to kill but what about an
undead one that just takes it to another
level like regular liches dragons can go
through the same rituals to become
undead beasts dracoliches can control
undead creatures on top of using
whatever powers and abilities they had
in life depending on a dragon type and
age they can be up to 50 feet long with
a skeletal appearance and torn wings but
with immense power and super fast flight
number four a bit theon
generals of the demonic armies of the
nine hills having been cleansed within
the pit of flame pithians achieved
levels of wickedness beyond that of
ordinary devils becoming beings of pure
unimaginable evil they are 12 feet or
3.7 meters tall and weigh 360 kilograms
or 800 pounds
pithions had a gargoylish appearance
thanks to a pair of enormous bad-like
wings which they frequently wrapped
around their terrifyingly red bodies
their prehensile tails could snap like
whips and their enormous fangs dripped
with hissing green venom
number three the kraken regarded as gods
of the seas in this universe or old gods
krakens were feared across the known
world they were creatures that dwell in
the depths of the ocean and came to the
surface to prey upon ships and crews
the average kraken was about a hundred
feet long miners plus their tentacles
and weigh about four thousand pounds or
1.8 tons they were highly destructive
and evil beings destroying all life from
tropical beaches
enslaving and breeding humans in their
underwater caverns to feed on them later
on
number two wagner a lich is evil and
powerful by itself but one that has
transcended such a state is beyond
comprehension such is the case with a
human lich called wagner who became a
god
while he was once considered the most
powerful lich to dwell on that world
over the ages he spent in undead wagner
became maligned across the multiverse
and was considered the scourge of all
civilizations
although very powerful and scary he was
only the size of a normal man
but don't be fooled he is the scorch of
the multiverse
and number one the tarasque standing 50
feet tall and 70 feet long this is the
most powerful monster to exist in the
material plane of that universe the
taurus was an enormous abomination with
two long horns extending from its
forehead a thick carapace a killer tail
many spikes covering its large body
especially the back and a white deadly
mouth although the terrace was
indisputably a force of pure destruction
it was not truly evil or even chaotic by
nature there is only one of them in the
core of the world and when it awakes it
is impossible to predict but it is
immune to all kinds of magic and attacks
and that makes it the deadliest monster
in this list
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video anyway with that we come to the
end of it so do hit that like button for
support subscribe but most of all smash
that bell icon for regular updates on
new videos here on this channel take
care fam